another issue I want to mention today I
don't know if people get sick of hearing
about this issue but I think it's
absolutely fascinating and this is
related to technological unemployment we
have this general sense that many jobs
are going to be replaced by machines in
the next 15 or 20 years there's a new
report now from Forrester which does
research into this type of economic
change that we're expecting and it's
much more specific within five years
the report says robots and so-called
intelligent agents some call it
artificial intelligence call it what you
want are going to replace positions in
customer service trucking and taxi
services which will total six percent of
jobs according to this Forrester report
this will be really in full force by the
year 2021 this is basically what we've
been saying for a long time right
customer service increasingly we've
reported on these sort of how would you
describe them I guess chat BOTS for lack
of a better term which can handle basic
customer service requests tracking
information order status refund requests
a lot of these things can really be
handled pretty well by a chat bot that
is going to replace jobs there's no
doubt about it
now you may be thinking well a lot of
those jobs have already been outsourced
to Asia yeah so some of the jobs that
are destroyed will not be in the US
they've already left the US but they'll
definitely not be coming back
transportation and taxi services well
yeah we've been talking about this for
years and we now know in Pittsburgh uber
has now rolled out self-driving taxis
you still need to have a driver able to
take over control if these self but the
autopilot were to fail but that is
already happening is also happening in
was Singapore or the Philippines we had
a story about that the trucking industry
we already see in Canada that autonomous
trucks are being used within --mines
transport or within the mine and we see
also the driverless truck corridor that
is a sort of test corridor in the
mountain zone
area I think it's in Nevada sort of
north-south around there and that that
is already happening so no surprise here
right I mean big picture we've seen
reports that say forty to forty five
percent of current human done jobs could
be replaced by technology the Forrester
report very very specifically saying in
the next five years it's going to be
about six percent of jobs primarily in
customer service trucking and taxi
services you're probably sick of hearing
me say this by now the only way that
we're going to move past this in a
positive manner as humans is if we
rethink the relationship to work do we
really need to be working 45 hours a
week in order to accomplish what is
necessary to participate in society in a
meaningful way or can we look at basic
income can we get beyond scarcity when
it comes to food well we could if we had
better food distribution in the
political will to make sure nobody goes
hungry there's really no reason people
should have to work for food once we
start losing jobs to robots and AI if we
had the political will to solve that
problem so every single report the
interesting thing is there's no reports
left that say hey you know what
automation won't be a problem don't
worry about it everything's gonna be
fine you drive a truck you're not gonna
lose your job you operate taxi you're
gonna be absolutely fine there is no
report now that it's saying that we
talked about with climate change well
it's like 99 to 1 or 99.7% to 0.3% that
humans are impacting the climate I've
not seen a single report arguing that
automation is not going to be an issue
for jobs in the United States or on the
in the world that should really tell us
something is usually you have some
devil's advocates